تابعنا معنا هذه الفيديوهات تم بثها هذا
اليوم تابعت ايضا ما جرى في الميدان
المؤشرات السياسيه وما يجري على الارض
نريد قراءه عسكريه لهذا التزامن بين هذين
المسار المسارين وكيف تقرا
المشهد عبد القادر وكانه هناك عمليه تسريع
اسرائيليه قبل ان يتم الاتفاق على وقف
النار وتبادل اسرى هذا اذا حصل لانه لدى
مقاومه شروط حتى الان لم تلبى اليوم عندما
نتحدث عن المرحله بشكل عام هناك ما يسمى
بعمليه الامتداد او التمدد والانحسار
للمقاومه يعني عندما يهاجم جيش الاحتلال
تتراجع المقاومه لتقاتل ضمن الخطوط
الداخليه وبالتالي عندما ينسحب او يتراجع
تعود ايضا للتمدد وبالتالي القيام بعمليات
خاصه اعاده التنظيم على سبيل المثال في
بدايه الحرب كان هناك ما يقارب 12 كتيبه
للمقاومه او القسام في شمال غزه هذا
التنظيم يعيد ترتيب نفسه جغرافيا يعني هذا
الامر جغرافيا لكل منطقه المسؤوليه الخاصه
فيها اليوم عندما ننتقل الى خان
يونس الدمار والتدمير وهنا عبد القادر
اريد ان اذكر ما نشرته اليوم جريده
النيويورك تايمز عن التدمير الممن
للهدف الامني والعسكري يعني اذا
راينا امكنه التدمير هذا الامر يعطينا اي
مرحله يريد الجيش العدو او السياسه
الاسرائيليه ان تضع تغيير الخارطه
للاستغلال والاستعمال الامني للمرحله
القادمه يعطيك فكره واضحه تماما وهذا امر
خطير جدا للمرحله القادمه جنوبا شمالا
اللواء
الياس هي هي تبدا من بيت حنون من بيت لهيا
من الشاطئ مخيم الشاطئ في الوسط ح حول
خانيونس والاهم دائما والاهم دائما هو لم
يترك شيء مهم يفتح الطرقات لعمليات التدخل
المستقبليه كي لا يكون هناك عوائق تدمير
خزاعه هو من ضمن المنطقه الامنيه مثلا
وبالتالي السعي لترتيب واقع معين مع مصر ل
كوريدور فيلا
وهذا الامر عبد القادر يذكرني قرات في
مكان ما عن اريال شارون بالعام 71 دخل الى
جباليا الى رفح دمر المنازل حولها صنع
منطقه امنيه شق الطرقات فيها وقسمها الى
مربعات لتسهيل العمل الامني في مكان ما
وخلال سبعه اشهر دمر 6 الاف منزل هذا
الامر ليس بجديد على القوات الاسرائيليه
هي تعد الارضيه الهندسه الميدانيه لاي
عمليه عسكريه مستقبليه تكون سهله عليها في
حال الخطر ايضا بالنظر لخصوص التوقيت
عندما يخرج وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ويقول
نكاد نكون قد انهينا المهمه في خان يونس
والمرحله القادمه هي رفح رفح عقده العقد
بالنظر للبعد الانساني وكذلك الجانب
الجغرافي باعتبار ملاصق للجانب المصري
ماذا عن
رفع
الهدف الاسمى البعيد المدى هو حتى انهاء
رفح
ودفع المهجرين قصرا من الغزاويين الى
منطقه المواصي وبالتالي فرض امر واقع على
المعبر الهدف دائما هو منطقه امنيه عزل
غزه تماما وبالتالي وهذا ما ورد البارحه
في جيروزالم بوست عن مشروع لنتنياهو
يتبناه رجال اعم
يقول انه عزله تماما وبالتالي فرض امر
واقع على مصر لمنع دخول اي شيء الى غزه
دون مراقبه اسرائيليه فاذا انت امام مرحله
جديده ولكن يبقى ماذا سيحصل في خان يونس
ماذا عن الانفاق وهي العقده وماذا عن
الصواريخ لضرب الداخل الاسرائيلي وهذا هو
العقده الاهم ايضا